here's our first thing by Inc hey guys
this is captain King mistake and today I
have a sinking submission this is my
tattoo it's a snake that's yours too
it was a happy little accident well
we'll watch the rest of this one I like
the we'll just skip right to the next
one right now I saw that Miami porno
can't give a Japanese what is that a
snake yeah it's just a snake alright the
next one
Laci
raw power whatever you want to call it I
don't know what it is just below that
some modest mouse lyrics this is the
part of me that needs medication
Thanks yeah life's crazy out here over
here black flag bars logo wall power
black poor hair I got my best friend
shouts out to CJ Hale is he still alive
you know we're here bro goddamn mess
with his fing school I got that when I
was really drunk cheering some game in
Florida last but not least demon system
13 is a another punk-rock baby shower
Santo is Swedish thrash yeah Boise still
alive you think a black guy has a tattoo
of someone who's still alive on her yeah
that's awesome I own but dude but rest
in peace
yeah
he's thing I talk oh damn that's you
getting the tattoo now is Joe Rogan with
hair giving you the tax in Coleman man
how long did you get that raw power -
that was two years ago that [ __ ] was
horrible
yeah that was the most painful probably
more painful ones yeah David tattoos are
intense bro yeah that could be Joe Rogan
with hair doing tattoos run Mesa Arizona
damn babe overall powers from an album
yeah it's an album by Iggy Pop and the
Stooges and then Modest Mouse what was
the most famous Modest Mouse load on we
all flown on alright alright okay why'd
you looked at those you saying it's so
aggressive
well alright then Lupe Fiasco sampled it
yep
in Graceland yep Brendan so what I'm
saying is this dude um does what I'm
saying is Chappell's tattoos a pretty
dope it's late your only tattoo cat have
another one yeah well I'm a rip what is
it
it's a CS Lewis quote Oh CS Lewis an
author
it's a ck Lewis quote which quote is it
cat there's nothing worse than to
explain tattoos is there I hate it
Oh would you get that [ __ ] cuz I wanted
to where there's a whole segment cuz I
like I know you personally know someone
you know I like Julia got a tattoo I was
like oh that's guy was like budget I
mean you have to explain why you guys
let me just see the art that's cool dude
I think that fish had something minute
bro iron or something levy to Lee sleepy
it's called work y'all yeah that does it
I feel good
yeah your tattoos are pretty cool if
people didn't know you just had your
shirt off like oh he served ten years oh
yeah but they get close you like or it's
a Thrasher my
[Laughter]
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]